if you have cancer your doctor may
recommend targeted cancer cell therapy
the cells in the body grow and divide as
part of the normal cell cycle
the cell's nucleus controls this process
inside each nucleus genetic material
called DNA contains the instructions for
directing this process
sometimes the cells DNA becomes damaged
normally the DNA responds by either
repairing itself or instructing the cell
to die
in cancer however the parts of the cells
DNA that direct cell division become
damaged
when these sections are damaged the DNA
is unable to repair itself or cause the
cell to die instead the unrepaired DNA
causes the cell to grow and divide
uncontrollably into more damaged cells
called cancer cells
a tumor forms as the cancer cells
multiply and displace the normal cells
as the tumor enlarges it develops its
own blood supply
since cancer cells do not stick together
as well as normal cells they may break
away and enter a nearby blood vessel
cancer cells in blood vessels may travel
to other areas of your body and form
additional tumors this is called
metastasis additional tumors may form in
areas such as the lungs
liver
and bones
another way cancer may spread to other
areas of your body is through your
lymphatic system
cancer cells may enter lymph vessels
near the tumor then travel to small
glands called lymph nodes
if the cells pass through the nodes they
may continue to travel through your
lymphatic system and form additional
tumors
if you have cancer your doctor may
recommend targeted cancer cell therapy
targeted cancer therapy attacks features
common to cancer cells while limiting
damage to your normal cells there are
two types of targeted therapy one type
includes small molecule drugs that work
inside your cancer cells the other type
includes drugs called monoclonal
antibodies that work on the outside of
your cancer cells
these therapies work in one of four ways
some block signals that cancer cells use
to make new cancer cells others deliver
toxic substances that kill or damage
cancer cells
some therapies stimulate cells in your
immune system to destroy cancer cells
others block the growth of new blood
vessels around cancer cells which
starves the cells of the nutrients they
need to grow
depending on which drug your doctor
recommends you may receive an oral
medication an injection or an
intravenous infusion
if you receive an intravenous infusion a
needle will be inserted into a vein in
your hand or arm a bag containing the
medication will be hung nearby with a
tube connecting the bag to the needle
the medication will drip slowly through
the tube into the needle then pass into
your bloodstream when you have received
a dose of the drug the needle will be
removed
after you receive targeted therapy your
doctor will monitor your vital signs to
be sure you do not have any side-effects
you will go home the same day